Prince wha-what is the most important
part of beginning a production in terms
of production design like when you begin
what are the first few things you're
doing in the very beginning of its to
read the script carefully and and and
and even before because it had now in
these days of age you receive the scrip
and after that you meet the director
that's a process you like so you read
the script and you do a quick research
on you know or quick research on the
period and what's the implication of
this and you you like absolute either so
have I'm based on the script you know
this is when it's not in the script for
me does it doesn't mean anything you so
I read the script carefully and
depending where we are you know in the
future world and now or in a period its
Renaissance and and trying to to put my
head in this visual the visual context
of the film and after that you sit down
with the doctor he tell you it's it's
own reading of the script and now you
starting a conversation you know you're
starting to have an exchange of just
bowled concept you know nothing nothing
specific and after that you start
working Francois a quote from your
personal site is from you yes and it
refers to you say when I work on a film
set I try to give it a theatrical feel
and conversely when I work my a theater
set I try to give it a film feel so tell
us the difference in each and any
similarities
I like said that in the movie that are
they they bring a lot of information and
the app it's a it's a very subtle
difference I mean I like a lot of
texture like in the theater you know
when I start there i start i did oprah
and there's a lot of texture and say now
the oprah taters thought that Taylor
language tried been much simplified it's
much more stark I like it though I like
it then when I tried to justify it says
and let Sofia complicated um well yeah I
take hard set I like you know like on in
Brooklyn my feeling it's the little the
little house of miss Kelly where's
upstairs short season 2 which right
she's a hard horrible woman for me it's
a little bit tatra chol you know this
over stuff there with plant and you know
and and and appear I would never do that
the theater would be more texture into
stark or more abstract more something
with yo the up is a tall window with
light and you know it's a little bit
more I don't know difficult okay maybe
is it more understated with film yeah
because it's just this little window
that we're saying okay that makes sense
you talked about the first step of
beginning production is when you look at
the script do you go somewhere to digest
the script because you know we have so
many distractions I see these people
working at Starbucks and bless their
heart I don't know how they do it I what
are you going somewhere maybe even in
nature somewhere to really get a feeling
for what oh yeah usually I go in a park
okay and your goodness I sit there I
like to be sitting outside right so I
honestly very often i read my script on
on the public space but Nana Kathy
doesn't work for me right too much going
on no okay I drink too much coffee and
isn't it good for a lot of people
watching to ya when you design for a
specific place do you actually go there
physically or is it enough for you to
just see pictures on the internet can
you taste almost smell a place just by a
picture or do you really need to be
there um it's really helpful to go there
really helpful sometimes it doesn't mean
anything but even like I did I did what
the Borgia you know even if it's honest
honest it's 14 something I still went to
Rome a new Rome but I went back to Rome
to read it with with the eyes of okay I
have to do st. Peter's have to do st.
Peter's Square even it is not the same
we couldn't copy because the st. Peter
that at that time was that the same one
that it's now so because it's right
after him the demolish and yo and
Colangelo paint the ceiling but at that
time it was it was Silda the early early
church so it was a church from 1800 but
I went to Rome to first of all why not
going sure yeah good good excuse yeah
yeah yeah so I'm not it's it's I did the
many movie that were on the road lot
Japan Tilly we shuttin you know the red
violin five countries so I it's very
good to go there sometimes they say it
won't happen you know nobody wants to
pay you to go attack but most of the
time you get I don't need to mow I don't
need a doctor to come with me you know
sure you can call just me and and
trying to and add I know now I do a lot
of internet but for many years I have a
huge library related to it would fill
this room so have lots of book gun so i
go there and so for Brooklyn did you go
to Brooklyn and also Ireland we shot in
Darwin so we went there we scout for
maybe two weeks one week the doctor was
sitting in the in the in the car with us
he was very open and with that's where
we really connect John Crowley yeah it's
a little bit unusual that a director
would spend like a week in a car with
the designer looking application and
what were you doing like where were you
going stopping at different roadside no
no no trying to find the town where she
lives and you know and find a connection
house and because it's it's limited
number of scene but we still she has to
go out and walk to the dance hall and
and the general store you know and so we
need stuff and johnny's irish show you
more and but we scout and scout and we
end up shooting in a in a scotty which
is it the town that it's written in the
book and the novel the same place by so
we had two or three village and you know
ABC and where we went down down down and
we took it and it Scotty you think back
to when you were a child what you did
for fun that prepared you for what you
do now were you artistic yeah well your
parents artists know in early college I
want to do movie you know I was when I
was I guess I saw Anthony you know that
the tennis player which is it what's it
with David he's a photographer Vanessa
Redgrave and David Hemmings yeah and 60
okay so I want to be a filmmaker I
didn't know what it meant but I want to
be one so and and and if some friend
were in the theater in college and they
say come with us and I say but I'm too
shy to go and say on stage and the guy
said but ok just deal with the set so I
start there and I was with 17 and that's
it that's all and that's how you got
your start alright did that and I
thought that I went to tears cool and I
finished year in school that always 21
years old and that's it so then from
that point on how did you begin booking
work uuuuu in the tier you start doing
you know props and you assistant to a
designer and you do drawing and you do
technical drawing and this is I'm
talking about 1970 you know then slowly
and one point I we did the play a doctor
wants to do a version for the television
so he took the same designers it's was
me so I start doing I did one project
with them and after that yet another
project but so we are me so all slowly I
was a set the Creator I was an art
director but that's I was still missed
mixing boat as a designer in theater and
set the creator and art director in a
movie and I start doing more and more
movie and less and less theater and had
two kids I couldn't stop and they want
to go to school and you know so because
theater it's a difficult to make money
what are small touches maybe that you
can make for for film not for theater
but that you can say a lot about a
character or a mood with those small
touches because yeah you you as a
production designer you work with said
the crew
so and and they a lot of times they
bring you stuff because they think
Europe you are in charge a little bit
the big picture and they they focus on
one thing so and after that do you you
know that we of course it's Ireland so
this car suffix everywhere I remember I
saw it the last time yesterday for the
first time on the big screen and there's
a low near lights which is a little
cross affixed I didn't remember putting
into there I guess is the set decorator
but I thought it was a nice touch this
one out on the short movie like this
from what I saw yesterday did was add a
little personal problem with some of the
stuff I did but hopefully nobody was
going to see it but it's part of a deal
it shoot a movie like this in 35 days
with that amount of budget then with
shooting in the tree country you know
sure it's free to you have to recruit
one because when I was the only one
traveling you know it was not one team
that go that went to Ireland moved back
to Montreal and went to to Brooklyn it
was me going and having a new crew all
the time so it's a little bit sure so
you're getting used to people's skill
set no no but it's a and you have to
start again the line you know it's a
little bit but it that's the only way to
make sense anyway so sure well who are
you working with and who is who is on
your team whether it's in Montreal
whether it's in Brooklyn whether it's in
Ireland so the breakdown of the of our
department team in that scale of a movie
you have an art director asset deck and
a prop person and graphic basically the
set dec sometimes I have one assistant
depending or two depending on the first
of all this different way of making sure
in different country you know not the
same in Italy not the same in in Ireland
that in America and
so you have to adapt but it's this is
the thing it's just a structure is
different you know that person does that
and that person in in another country
the shift it's a you know the
responsibility is a little bit different
but basically is we do the same same job
so you have this so the art director a
construction coordinator set deck and a
prop basically that's a corpus you know
and on that you a little bit outside you
have the people who deal with the car
that or it's another tribe the car
people it's another tribe because you
basically you have to deal with
collector and it's always a bit tricky
to get a collector coming you know with
their car okay in that case we didn't we
didn't have to deal with the breakdown
of the car you know when when it's a sad
story and you want to have a dirty car a
punch-up car but it's nineteen thirty or
nineteen fifty but this one it's all
proper it was easy you know all the car
there was no reason to make them beat up
or you know it was okay it's when you
get the movie when you need beat up car
period that's a nightmare how much are
you looking at the monitor when you're
filming a movie or maybe you're not I'm
personally I'm there every morning to if
it's a new set I'm there to present the
set to DP and the doctor and everything
I stay there until the first shot in a
leaf I'm not I can't stay there first of
all I'm not too keen on the
you know that mustard it's too slow for
me so and usually I have something else
to do so I I I talk I prison if it's a
set with different change I might come
back you know let's say we have to
change its later they move or you know
something happened in the in the script
that the set need change I will be there
but I don't say there I just stay there
for the first shot and when it's done a
leaf because I have to prepare the next
day there was going to be somewhere else
ah so that's what you're going to the
neither the next location or the next
let's say studio part this to yo you
have to go and and and need the set
decorator whose dressing to set the new
true you have to go to the curtain and
look at the wallpaper for the next X X
so we if you it it's my my my way of
working i don't say there I feel like it
it's not fair for all my my team that
happen come and see me on the set and
show me wallpaper leave John I'm I'm um
you know i'ma craftsmen so I have to go
I have to go and it's been working fine
this way